[Applause]
[Music]
are you an athlete let me see you just
naturally come through like you got a
ball on your hand right here not time to
panic yet he should probably panic a
little bit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the homies have arrived they're having a
good time live at Dan Tana's Atlanta and
since dirt wins over here like we get
all you crazy people we got ourselves
somebody's special and all-pro safety in
his very first season he said you're not
going to take me to 17 then I'm gonna
smash it in your face because it's
Derwent James can I get more for the
fans so easy to you but it's fun you
know being able to go out there and make
plays on Sunday so there's a lot of fun
all right so two teams in the Superbowl
two teams that beat the Chargers not a
lot of teams that beat the charges is
here and I'm not trying to come out
negative stuff no but the truth is is
like you're gonna know these teams
better than any of us and I'm curious
did you think that these were two of the
best teams you faced and what did you
learn about them facing them those two
teams were two of the best things that
we faced this year I feel like Tom Brady
they're not gonna wow you with the
athletes and stuff but I feel like they
come and execute every game and they're
gonna be what I need to be and then the
Rams they have a game-changing players
like Aaron Donald and Todd Gurley so
there's two different teams but if I had
to pick I say in the pages with New
England with you guys pretty good oh
good yeah that was a good one
what was that experience like just I
mean to see that machine machine go up
into Foxborough I'm sure they were
yelling a lot of creative stuff at you
guys yeah and did you get like an awe of
Brady or them at all throughout game I
mean going against Brady it was fun
because like I said they came by they
had a good game plan they execute it and
we we didn't come out and play in the
first half and then we got down too far
and I'm like I say you're not gonna come
back and once he gets a lead over there
are you the most famous James in LA
domain playing sports I might be man hey
I might be I don't know but we got a
good reason for Aetna so I was watching
like your IG and stuff from the Pro Bowl
and I'm seeing all these great players
in the field where I'm saying like you
and Keenan Allen and Jalen Ramsey and
is if you could make Derwin James's best
secondary two corners another safety and
you who would be your and not including
Chargers so we don't
sorry teammates no Chargers who would be
your ultimate secondary I say jailor at
one corner I have to go Patrick Peterson
pile at another corner and I put me in
Jamal back there come on out of the 233
back there is there because I feel like
you guys you're gonna be competing for
all-pro spots and all that but I feel
like you guys play so similar is there
out like a friendship there - yeah we
got we got a great friendship I mean
we've grown over the last year I've
known each other we were say to each
other game and I feel like you're gonna
do a great thing that I'm gonna do a
great thing is we have a number of
meaningless debates that I would like
you to help us settle I don't know what
side you're on
I don't know what side you're on I don't
even on the side I'm on Waffle House at
2 p.m. or 2:00 a.m. I kind of feel grimy
when I go there at 2:00 p.m. I agree
hell am i doing in here my girlfriend is
never go in the morning man good my
girlfriend's ever be able to go a lot I
would go at 2:00 p.m. you don't want to
see it you don't want the Sun coming in
and see what the hours look like no this
is a debate that we have had on the
podcast forever
if there was a fight between a grizzly
bear and a lion who would win that fight
a lion so your team Sims I believe at
the bear walk destroy the line because
the lion can only attack straight
forward and even if he bites the bear
you have the monster bear claws coming
down he could tear them apart we have
seen video yes that bear lion has are
too hard too hard time with the bear it
hurt my heart I want to since I had to
put it down I think I can't see this yes
Rorty real yeah it's been well dr. lion
is so muscular he fatigues out yes it's
like he cuz the mayor so thick and fat
he doesn't bother him and the mayor is
like Fletcher
and the lion is like Darwin or Jane
right eventually he's gonna go are you
done so okay new battle Derwent James
Fletcher Cox how would you do
how many Fletcher boxes how many Adam
left goes would it take to beat up
Fletcher Cox Oh meaning how many of me
we all got enough for okay I don't think
four would do it you know I obviously
know I think five maybe I think 12 I
think if we had if we had one left go on
each limb and then a fifth one to
finally go to the body in the head you
know you're overestimating very much all
right can we get a round of applause I'm
JJ Watt and you're watching Simpson left
go
[Applause]
feels so good the homies the homies the
homies all right well we got to talk
about the game yeah Sunday yeah Patriots
Rams I've never sat this far from I
don't really far what's going on over
there so the line
according to Caesar's arguably the best
casino I've ever seen in my entire life
is Patriots by two and a half I want to
know your last thoughts going into the
game to aid my pick for this game right
off the bat if you win the toss don't
make the same mistake Andy Reid made
right which was he deferred and kicked
it to Tom Brady and company
don't let New England don't let the
train get rolling that would be the
first thing I would say if I'm the Rams
I'm gonna take the ball you might go
three and out whatever it may be only a
first down but your defense is gonna get
on the sidelines they're gonna be able
to get geared up a little bit and I
would just worry about if you let Brady
in the New England machine and all their
game planning come out the first drive
and just all gosh here it goes it's
pulling guards it's screens its Brady
down the middle and full air leaves the
stage air everyone's going here's Tom
Ray and the Rams are gonna go damn this
is uh we haven't seen this this is I
guess this is the Patriots and I worried
about that aspect and your big thing if
the if the Rams when I have a chance is
they have to set up on defense right
away yes it's one of my big issues with
the Rams in the Saints game and it's
been an issue for them all year and I
know and Lefko pointed this out with my
notes last week when when this the
Patriots see a flaw like that and they
start to go through a game and they go
man there were 60 snaps in this game at
about 25 of them the Rams are still
talking into each other when the snap
was going on
no England is going to have a package of
plays they say that's a Tennessee
exactly offs last year where they just
say one word like guys a might it might
be tequila all right and they're gonna
say tequila and they're gonna know the
formation to line up in and they're
gonna know the play they're running and
there's gonna be no talk it's gonna be
get up there quick and Brady's just
gonna hit the guy in the but they're
gonna snap it and go and all of a sudden
the Rams are gonna be all flustered if
they feel like they get a little success
there they're gonna keep continuing to
do that so those are little things I
watch on the Rams got to keep it close
early if it goes because no way yeah
first quarter
night-night there
in trouble but if we get through the
first quarter and it's six three seven
yeah he you know anywhere in that range
then the Rams I think got a chance the
Rams got to get some stops early on
because if they are on the field too
much you guys have heard me I worried
that the thinness of the roster hurts
all right talk about the caesars line
we had a big competition can Adam left
co the legend that he is throw the ball
50 yards Vegas set the line at 50 yards
you said over and then I closed and I
thought he would get it but as I got
here Super Bowl week I was like you know
that's gonna be more fun if he doesn't
get it so I'm gonna root of root against
them so let's go and let's get into it
all right so here it is for the first
time I'll reveal the 50-yard challenge
oh my gosh comes to me today and they
make it about themselves they make jokes
we have credentials as we are a serious
journalism official and we're here to
see if the Rams and Patriots believe I
can throw the ball 50
here at Johnny hacker who is kind of
known for your are more than your leg
these days best throwing the funner I've
ever seen Wow okay so we were doing a
pod and he looked at me and he went left
oh I think you can throw it 50 yards
like that's all I'm gonna give you is
that motion I think that's a good
endorsement maybe are do whatever you
want you can do a somersault thank you
no oh like holidays I mean 50 yards not
easy now if you look a little more like
Brady and my man Chris here maybe but
you - you know what it is you got
somebody must do swathi he's got a big
ticket for the bomb 50 yards we just
want you think he can size in my field
and then gonna get thrown 15 you know
look at this eye and say that they've
okay look at that motion do you think he
can throw that the arts Marcus Pete how
a cirrus it's a different stroke baby
pose oh no I mean you've got back beer
what do you think Hector said yes CJ
said no 50 50 yards I got you to the 35
30
he thinks he can throw the ball 50 yards
no way no way what ain't no way no way
no way my quarterback so good what
advice would you give her listen don't
over grip the ball okay right don't over
stride yeah you be launch if you get
some areas like the cemetery they may
get away with her own trajectory are you
an athlete let's come out really let me
see you just naturally come through like
you got a ball on your hand right here
all right so change you're throwing it
50
[Music]
lene 50 yards this far don't overthrow
your first one book left go 45 47 ish
those last three or four yards are very
hard to get I'm channeling my inner dick
false no one can explain it it's magic
sometimes magic yeah
dan at that time 48 yards 48 I mean I
guess I'm getting more Vegas always
knows where to sit the line all day
thirty yards is your call of the day not
time to panic yet he should probably
panic a little bit
what was that
49 are you kidding so costs want to
touch the 50
I think that's all she wrote
[ __ ] and now my arms throwing up my arms
dead it was a good try hey they're
really likes it was so close
I mean you backed up 49 you got the 40
I'm not even gonna lie I really didn't
think you were even get there once I saw
you warm up I tried I thought I had it
but I can't I guess I'm a 49 then I'm
just you know yeah that's what I'm
capable of
oh man yeah I'm just gonna tell you guys
to get to 49 is like the most
bittersweet thing ever so much so that I
thought he was lying about the half a
yard he really was he was like are you
lying and I was like I would not cheat
you I appreciate you guys I know you
supported me so thank you for helping me
try to get the fell way to go left go
you're a good sport man all right no
joke so uh next up two guys that could
definitely throw the ball 50 yards two
guys that think they're better football
friends than us I'm Chad Johnson and
Terrell Owens ever
[Music]
do you guys know that when it comes to
best football friends Sims and myself
believe that we are the cream of the
crop and we've looked all over the NFL
to see who can compete with this
connection nobody found two guys that
want to take the test Sims how dare they
why don't you introduce them you mean
Bjorn the German DJ over there yes that
I know Joe Cinco Bjorn the no-tech no
I'm taking over my name is Tommy Shelby
Shelby apparently and we have the Hall
of Famer
oh it's Terrell Owens so here's how this
is gonna work we have a lot of
competitions to see whose connection is
stronger not only that we also have the
referee from the end of the Rams Saints
game that decided not to throw the flag
killer I'm only kidding I'm only kidding
oh he will be the arbiter to see who was
right who was wrong this is gonna get
very competitive watch the I would say
we could bring Roger Goodell in this
situation but he's of no use
yeah hello though that got a lot do they
are you guys ready got your game faces
on
they up just wait for the Jeopardy tune
here we go in what year the Chad lead
the NFL in receiving yards Wow hilarious
I don't even know we don't have it we
don't have most I don't remember no
hints
no hey write down your years enough with
this no I don't even remember I sorta
guys so write down a year
go ahead well you're good we don't keep
up with stats like that right
I think I can only leave right now no
there's damn rules all right they're
mine don't look at lo look at how hard
your stuff telepathic stop Rick what is
Tio's middle name yeah what Susie
Charles like oh that's easy I know my
own little lame what is his middle name
and it's not handsome
just my it's not handsome wait a minute
we haven't gotten that far in our
relationship
hey that's why you're not gonna be the
best football dad if he gets this dog
fall out all right dad floor I went with
what makes sense to me and it flows you
know so about this is mom this is what I
would named him here's a deal that makes
sense though like my face you got the
first letter right at the first level
Terrell's middle name is El Dorado what
was like the furniture store like my car
can we put like a asterisk by that
because there's no way I was known his
name was El Dorado well if you have a
middle name like that
yeah that's like El Dorado there's a
reason he didn't tell me because I want
to still be making fun of knowledge did
tio attend oh I'm talking about man
this is what relationships are about
here we go three two one slip up
something some train chatter some
whatever
here we go let it go question how many
career TD's did tio have within ten I
mean I know right off the top my head
really then write it write it down
153 within ten correct
oh yeah shorted all right who touchdowns
I did yeah we should have in mind they
should make a bar a couple are you
gentlemen ready to defend your house we
already can all right here we go
starting with a left question what
popular diet did left go do for 30 days
in the summer of 2017 Wow I'm not sure
about this but I got it I think I got a
peg for what he would do Oh Mac is diet
diet
I don't think someone's done the a crazy
there's lots of play are you about it
later
I never heard about that before yeah
vegan diet yes I talked about it on the
podcast damn I don't remember that
clearly he wasn't listening
apparently not Eldorado yeah hey you
could be mad at sorry sorry matter he
got emotional hey back there clearly hey
Ethan we got it wrong damn it man I'm
sorry who is Sims favorite female singer
I do I do I do concentrate concentrate
Faith Hill no no you're not
you two I don't think you're gonna even
know who this person is Oh Miranda
Lambert
[Applause]
a lot of yeah way to go thanks friend
that's red well done
I'm happy to carry this team yet again
sips what was Sims Asst highest Maddon
rating I'm not even sure I know this one
damn what do you what do I think I was I
get this right and he gets this wrong
gosh damn a serious problem I stopped
playing once I got in the game gun I
didn't want to do it anymore it's in the
game damn I'm not gonna lie there was a
time where I drafted Chris Sims in one
of the league's on Madden did you really
but for cap concerns I had to cut you ah
what is left goes birthday oh I had a
feeling alright so if you've watched the
show 504 to my balls you on his birthday
okay four three two one hey best friend
how you doing best friend it's all tied
up at froze guys and then it's a trace
breaker gentlemen Ginga your first wait
first of all what what are you what you
got like you doing finger exercises oh
absolutely I'm always prepared so I
didn't even notice but I'm always
prepared that's not good for this I mean
you're gonna have a heavy fingers that's
good oh it was first I heard you're
first okay go go yeah come on go for it
well paper-rock-scissors will go first
okay good
just touch all of them t and it is one
hand right yes oh we could end right
here oh it could end right here I mean
this st. I told you those exercises
weren't gonna help in this game
[Music]
[Applause]
the member has have been easier to
figure out who the best football friend
science
happening Wow you think you're the
champion are you kidding me
quality time we are here and there's a
belt guys
this is Trent a long large tittle of the
San Francisco 49ers they beat us in best
football friends crap you heard these
dudes I'm good I'm just gonna be honest
I'm really intimidated should be wait so
what happens now are you gonna face us
they want to face all we already beat
you guys this ain't no around Rob just
came into our house and we're getting
reamed for getting a rematch sorry we
beat you already Kendal and Trent Taylor
I need you some toys what the champions
go first
Oh Kittles the middle guy he's looking
at the second level hey you're good it's
dirty
they say he likes I don't like that but
he's pulling from the outside stop stop
holy cow Wow wiggle it just a little bit
oh dear move it move it pull it pull it
[Applause]
ah
it's back in home
yeah thank you its proper clay and what
do you know
proving yet again that seems a love poem
are the best football friends for George
kennel for trip Taylor for all the
homies at Dan Tana's thank you guys so
much
it's all ours honey boobs and love go
thank you guys enjoy the Super Bowl like
the Patriots who might lose in week one
but what it really counts that's all
that matters oh one more round of
applause for George for Don Jose back to
common good luck thank you guys